[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días el
magazine donde les presentamos la
actualidad del continente africano Mi
nombre es amalfman Y estos son los
titulares más de 93 millones de
nigerianos se preparan para elegir a su
próximo presidente el 25 de febrero
estas elecciones son tan cruciales para
el país como para la región de África
occidental tenemos análisis
impactantes revelaciones de un consorcio
de periodistas una sociedad secreta
israelí de desinformación habría
influido en varias elecciones africanas
finalizó la Cumbre de la unión africana
con la crisis nvidia y el comercio
continental entre los principales temas
abordados analizamos Estos y otros
puntos del encuentro con nuestra enviada
es de 25 de febrero los votantes de
Nigeria el país más poblado de África
acuden a las urnas para elegir a su
próximo presidente
estas elecciones se celebran en un
contexto de creciente descontento debido
a una crisis de inseguridad en aumento y
a las dificultades económicas un total
de 18 candidatos compiten por el cargo
Pero según los sondeos solo tres tienen
posibilidades reales de ganar
bola chinobu tiene 70 años y representa
al partido gobernante el congreso de los
progresistas ex gobernador de lagos se
sigue ejerciendo una gran influencia En
este estado pero tiene acusaciones de
corrupción en su contra
abubacar tiene 76 años y se presenta por
la principal formación opositora el
partido democrático popular ya se ha
presentado cinco veces a las elecciones
presidenciales pero nunca ha ganado
también ha sido acusado de corrupción y
de nepotismo
Peter Ovi de 61 años espera romper el
sistema bipartidista que domina Nigeria
desde el fin del régimen militar en 1999
hace parte del partido laborista y
cuenta con un fuerte apoyo en las redes
sociales y entre los jóvenes nigerianos
En qué situación se encuentra Nigeria y
qué le espera al próximo presidente para
hablar de ello nos acompaña Gil Yadi
fundador de wati centro de pensamiento
ciudadano de África occidental
Gil bienvenido Cuál es el balance de los
mandatos del presidente saliente
mohamedú
guarida
fue elegido con la promesa de reducir la
inseguridad que ha sido uno de los
principales problemas de Nigeria durante
mucho tiempo y también de encontrar
soluciones para la dificultades
económicas y sociales de este país que
es el más poblado del continente
africano
creo que su balance no es muy positivo
claramente
en materia de seguridad la situación no
ha mejorado al contrario
los focos de inseguridad se han
multiplicado en el país
en el plano económico vemos Que este
mandato está terminando en una crisis
vinculada en particular al lanzamiento
de nuevos billetes en naira la moneda
nigeriana
y esto está generando muchas
manifestaciones de violencia y muestra
las dificultades en la gobernanza
económica del país el 40% de los
votantes son jóvenes y esperan un cambio
real están los programas de los
candidatos a la altura de estas
esperanzas
Yo diría que los programas suelen ser
bastante interesantes desde el punto de
vista de tener en cuenta la demografía
del país la juventud del país y estos
considerables retos económicos y
sociales pero básicamente el problema es
la aplicación de los programas una vez
que tenemos un presidente electo Un
gobierno en funciones creo que en el
caso de Nigeria también hay que subrayar
que estamos en un país Federal en el que
los estados tienen un poder
significativo Así que la elección del
presidente es importante pero las
elecciones de los gobernadores de los
distintos estados también son
extremadamente importantes porque en
realidad tienen mucho margen de maniobra
en términos de políticas públicas Así
que es importante tenerlo en cuenta
creo que lo especial de estas elecciones
es que al contrario de lo que estamos
acostumbrados tenemos tres candidatos
que parecen ser importantes y por tanto
de trás de ellos tres partidos y no dos
como era tradicional Y tenemos un
candidato Peter Ovi que parece ser
especialmente popular entre los jóvenes
y que está haciendo hincapié en sus
promesas de campaña hacia ese sector de
la población
puede explicar la importancia de estas
elecciones en el contexto de una región
África occidental marcada por un
retroceso de la Democracia con golpes de
estado en países como Mali Guinea y
burkina faso
Nigeria es la primera potencia
demográfica es la primera potencia
económica no solo de África occidental
sino del continente creo que en gran
medida por el debilitamiento de la
organización regional que es la sedeao y
por tanto los problemas de paz y
seguridad en el y en la región en su
conjunto
cuando Nigeria es débil cuando tiene
problemas de liderazgo de hecho es toda
la región de África occidental la que se
ve afectada y la sedea ola que se
debilita Así que creo que lo que está en
juego en las elecciones de Nigeria es
absolutamente regional necesitamos un
liderazgo renovado en Nigeria que
también sea capaz de hacer que esta
federación asuma su responsabilidad
algo que no hemos visto desde hace 10 o
15 años Así que sí se trata de unas
elecciones absolutamente importantes
para toda la región y no solo para
Nigeria Cuáles Serán las prioridades del
próximo presidente
creo que quizás esta vez la urgencia
será en primer lugar económica porque
realmente tenemos una crisis en este
momento vinculada a una muy mala gestión
del lanzamiento de los nuevos billetes
de la moneda nigeriana que a su vez está
muy afectada con un alto nivel de
inflación y una pérdida de credibilidad
entre los nigerianos
Sí pues Esto será realmente inmediato
porque estamos en una situación de Gran
crisis vinculada a esta mala gestión
especialmente por parte del Banco
Central del lanzamiento de estos nuevos
billetes y luego por supuesto la
seguridad al nuevo presidente se le
espera también en el ámbito de la
seguridad Con promesas digamos es para
dar esperanza de que al final de su
mandato vamos a tener una mejor
situación que al final de los dos
mandatos del presidente bujhari Gil
Gracias por responder a nuestras
preguntas una investigación periodística
ha revelado la existencia de Tim Jorge
una empresa israelí que habría tenido
injerencia en decenas de elecciones
principalmente en el continente africano
según el consorcio de medios forbidden
Stories talán un exmilitar de la
inteligencia israelí lideraría este
grupo que se jacta de poder hackear
cuentas de email o redes sociales
iniciar campañas de influencia o
desinformación o crear múltiples
perfiles falsos nuestro corresponsal en
Jerusalén para Israel y los territorios
palestinos Federico cué Barberena repasa
la supuesta acción de Tim Jorge en
África injerencia en 33 campañas
presidenciales dos tercios en África
anglófona y francófona con resultados
exitosos en 27 de ellas Esa fue la
presentación que Tim Jorge le hizo a los
tres periodistas encubiertos del
consorcio forbidden Stories que
desenmascararon este grupo israelí
Mercenario de la desinformación que
contribuye a desestabilizar algunas
democracias africanas aún no
consolidadas entre los casos que se
constató una manipulación está la
elección presidencial de Nigeria en 2015
algo que genera revuelo en estos nuevos
comicios en los que se teme que las
noticias falsas puedan volver a afectar
a la democracia más grande de África De
acuerdo al consorcio de investigación
Tim Jorge se unió a la británica
Cambridge analítica para intervenir en
favor del entonces presidente nigeriano
good luck Jonathan Aunque aquellas
actividades no impidió la elección de
muamado bujhari si habría influenciado
en el aplazamiento electoral de seis
semanas el robo de información
confidencial de la campaña de bujari y
el bloqueo de su teléfono también el
diario británico de Guardian explicó que
este equipo israelí de hacke y cuentas
sociales falsas intervino en 2019 en
senegal a favor del presidente maquisal
con campañas de desinformación mediante
Bots digitales y la vigencia de Jorge
quedó evidenciada porque en su
demostración a estos periodistas
encubiertos explicó que estaba
involucrado en la última elección en
Kenia en 2022 así se jactó de cómo podía
generar confusión al entrar en cuentas
de mensajería de al menos de tres
asesores de William roto entonces
candidato y hoy presidente tras vencer
de forma ajustada al saliente rayla
odínga unos comicios marcados por las
acusaciones mutuas de fraude que era
Corte Suprema desestimó
la edición número 36 de la Cumbre de la
unión africana ha concluido en la
capital etíope Adis abeba seguridad paz
y economía han sido muchos los temas de
debate Cuáles fueron las conclusiones de
esta reunión nuestra enviada especial a
elizabeba Marian cone quien entrevistó
al ex presidente de
nígerfu nos amplía al final fueron los
anuncios sobre cuestiones de seguridad
lo que dominaron este cumbre de la unión
africana al primer anuncio se refiere a
la organización de un de una conferencia
de Reconciliación nacional inclusiva en
Libia antes de Junior será la
conferencia más inclusiva desde el
comienzo del conflicto libio desde los
dos gobiernos del país hasta los actores
de la sociedad civil incluidos los
miembros del Antiguo gobierno como los
hijos de cadafi también será la primera
vez que una conferencia de
Reconciliación nacional se celebre en el
territorio libio siguiendo con las
cuestiones de seguridad la unión
africana ha reafirmado que no querer
levantar las sanciones a Mali porque
nafasso y Guinea gobernados por juntas
militares fruto de golpes de estado y
como novedad la serie o prohibía a sus
dirigentes viajar en estos tres países
En cuántos en cuanto a los demás puntos
en la Cumbre de la unión africana se
dieron muy pocas respuestas se dio ni
una fe ninguna fecha ni medidas claras
sobre la aplicación de la zona del libro
cambio continental que era el tema de
esta Cumbre pero el expresidente de
asegurar que las cosas van por buen
camino
hoy 47 de los 55 estados han ratificado
este protocolo nunca hemos tenido tantas
ratificaciones poco tiempo en la
historia de La Unión africana en la
historia de la organización de la unidad
africana en los últimos
nunca hemos tenido un acuerdo que haya
avanzado tan rápido como el acuerdo de
la zona de libre comercio continental
africana
El proyecto dice cambios lanzado en 2018
debería permitir a los países africanos
y anticiparse de occidente aumentando el
comercio entra africano que actualmente
solo representa el 15% del comercio
total del continente
así termina esta edición de África siete
días Gracias por acompañarnos la
actualidad internacional sigue en
francés 24
[Música]